so the sort of the goal of this session
is to get into the nitty-gritty a little
bit of what it actually means to develop
for VR so we've got a fascinating
selection of panelists to take us
through some of the foundational aspects
of what it's like to actually develop
for VR so we got PC from resolution
games who's going to talk about what
it's like to develop for a medium where
the user has no expectations Bradley
from BBC is going to talk about
transitioning the brand and keeping kind
of the brand integrity into the new
medium and then kayfa marty is gonna
talk about this much-talked-about
dichotomy where interrelation between
linear and interactive experiences so
coming up guys
and pizza orbits you with with the first
lightning talk that you're gonna take us
through so I'm gonna look over there
okay
hi I'm Peter and I work with work at
resolution games we're based in
Stockholm Sweden and when we develop
games in virtual reality now we would
like to start in reality and then try to
bring the things that are interesting
into fantastic an example of that is one
of our games we had the fortunate to be
one of the launching titles for a
daydream and it's called Wanda glade and
it's basically doing something familiar
in an unfamiliar context so the example
from Wanda grade that is that throwing
up you know shooting hoops throwing a
basketball is very familiar and you
can't trick the brain you get it you got
to make it feel like you're throwing
that basketball but you're doing it on
the moon
that's kind of unfamiliar so that's what
really interesting and what the players
like the most Radley
thank you I'm Bradley from BBC Worldwide
so sometimes when a new kind of
technology comes along it's really
tempting to kind of get caught up in
what that technology can do for you and
maybe to forget some of the things that
make your brand what it is and you
should be thinking about the things that
make your brand what it is and they
might be as practical as the kind of
like the logos that you use or the color
schemes that you use and so on but
beyond that there should be there should
be other things in terms of kind of like
the brand values the things that can
represent your brand at a very kind of
like high level and really when you're
taking your brand into a new media like
VR you need to be rigorously applying
those kind of you know those sort of
checks and processes when you sort of
you take your brand into a new medium
and to give you an example we're doing a
lot of work at the moment with BBC Earth
brand so it's natural history content
some of you might be familiar with this
one of the last things that we did was
called planet Earth - there's a scene in
that where there's iguanas versus snakes
we call these kind of iconic scenes and
these are something that we tend to have
always when we put out our own kind of
what we called landmarks or easy-chair
but really this is just underpinning the
kind of brand values that make up what
BBC Earth is all about so those brand
values are things like the editorial and
scientific rigor we make sure that
everything we do in whatever medium is
rigorous in terms of its application of
kind of the kind of the science that we
apply probably the kind of the the the
biggest and most important thing is also
storytelling that's something that in
everything that we do and if you think
about it that kind of iguanas versus
kind of snakes example is a good example
of storytelling right and that's
something that we want to carry through
into all of the kind of like the media
that we do and all the content that we
produce so that's something that we're
thinking about when we're creating VR
experiences and finally and this is easy
with VR
we're thinking about innovation so that
doesn't necessarily come to mind when
you're thinking about BBC Natural
History content but actually every time
a new series comes out we're using new
technology we're either using new
cameras we're using drones to take
pictures we're using new submersible
techniques and again we want to carry
through that kind of brand value into VR
so the type
things the types of kind of content that
we're delivering the way in which people
interact and so on we want to innovate
with yeah that's me Kai from our our our
trigger for VR data was really that it's
in something at the medium which
attracts interest of all generations I
mean from kids to grandparents everybody
is attracted by by VR and is fascinated
by that but to get and to keep this
there's interest for VR productions we
started now in 2014 I think with the
first one it's really a key question is
really the interface and the
accessibility so interacting in VR
should be close to human behavior as
easy as breathing or drinking water it
should be really easy to seamlessly get
into into VR and and also the same for
for augmented reality for some projects
we're working on I would like to show
you two examples how we distinguish the
things a bit I mean one is that we do a
lot of more linear productions based on
360 video but also edit with metadata
which is for instance Topher man
seriously we have series we just
published so we take people to
exceptional places and to give access to
exceptional places in this example you
can really dive with free divers more
than 5 meters 10 20 meters 50 meters
down in the ocean you can swim with
dolphins and stuff like that and sperm
wells so something exceptional you
cannot live like that out of the box and
the second one is more interactive
experiences but also with the same goal
to be really seamless in terms of
navigation that's not some blindness
it's a story of a British man who lost
sight and he did the audio journal about
it and the fascinating thing with this
audience journal is that you really
explains extremely interesting what
happens to them so we did a VR
experience with French or French
partners about it
and it's extremely interesting after you
saw it you understand what it means to
lose sight and the interactive part in
that it's just based on the way you move
with sound with different things like
that you don't need to click on
something or anything it's just seamless
into into the whole experiences so these
are the goals we we are working on and
we're working on more and we are so
super amazing to have such a you know
wide cross-section of developers in the
room and I think probably let's make
this practical right so we've got
developers here who are perhaps thinking
of getting into VR and with that you
know what would be the number one piece
of advice that you'd give to someone who
is thinking of starting out in VR today
Bradley what would you say it's a good
question I think you know I've always
sort of said go in with your eyes opened
quite literally maybe you know it's it's
it's not an easy kind of medium to
develop for at first there's quite a
steep learning curve our first foray
into it we sort of thought wow this will
be relatively easy and I will sort of
know we'll crack a couple of kind of
experiences out there and you know get
them through submission and everything
took three times as long cost three
times as much as we were expecting and
actually to kind of go back to my point
I was making before to uphold the things
that are important to us about our brand
like the quality of the output and so on
actually took a significant amount of
time and I think it's only read just now
that we've really kind of you know
learnt how to approach that properly and
you know sort of do things in the right
way and that will be a sort of
continuing learning processes sort of
new tech comes out and so on so what
would you say that then in that sense to
someone who's just thinking of starting
out all right any of you guys that have
of a good piece of wisdom in terms of
the first thing to think about or the
first potential failure that you have to
think about in terms of developing for
the R
I would say start with the core start
simple one of my developers usually says
throw crap on the wall and see what
sticks and you got a try you got to try
a lot of things because it's a moving
platform it's a moving target that
you're aiming for you try and try to try
to try and come back to the things that
just feels good knowing what your
objectives are you know you have an end
goal what are you actually trying to
achieve with this you know you trying to
do this is from a commercial point of
view we're trying to do it from a brand
point of view what it you know what are
your objectives and that's probably true
of most ventures right but I think it's
particularly true with something which
combines a lot of creativity and a lot
of tech so it is like you say it's a
kind of a moving target and you know
sometimes it moves whilst you're
developing for it right so yeah I mean I
think it's good to have an end goal in
mind I think it's also extremely
interesting important to work on ideas
in a way that you have an idea and you
can put it in one sentence
and you pitch it to someone and it may
click and I think that's a key factor in
the beginning and then you add the text
to it but if you have this kind of basic
idea which really convince people and it
convinced you know a little bit of five
years or a granny of ninety and then you
think you you know that you were really
working on something interesting and
grave and which can be really great and
then you add the tech you had a
different ways of sound of cameras of
unity whatever you decide what you want
to use for it and that's I think a key
factor that's great I mean I think one
interesting mantra that we all know in a
mobile world is failed cheap and fail
fast and I just want to kind of drill
down on that a little bit in the context
of this question as well it kind of
works in mobile pretty well like you can
you know fail cheap and fail fast with
the R and the costs and the know-how
associated with developing for the R
that's presumably a lot harder to do so
how do you do you still apply the same
method or do you just not and you see
this as an investment of a different
kind and you have to convince perhaps
your leadership that this is just the
way it has to be
Pizza do you have a take on that yeah I
guess there was the crap on the wall and
she was taking you
yeah it does apply I think partially I
think you have to make a few bets I
think you got to pick a few things that
you actually believe is gonna happen
like for example we believe that you
know chords in VR kind of go away you're
gonna be moving around a lot more
there's a lot of those examples where
you gotta go that we really believe in
it's gonna happen because again it's
moving moving platform it does apply in
the sense that if you got to do
something that you are very unsure of
that if it's kind of successful and be
successful or not then yeah fail fast
that you can port your experience to
different other platforms to do real
life experiences in cinemas to to bring
it on mobile to bring it on on different
headsets and stuff like that I mean that
can really trigger the evolution and it
can help that with porting you redefine
the things you're doing so I think it's
really amazing to see that things
working great on the a dream but also on
Android but on Android they're known as
also some other assets and stuff like
that but still we can sort and
planetariums in screens which are 30
meter large and and you can watch it
together with with 300 people in a
cinema like setting so I think that's
really the interesting great thing with
we are today
that you own a step on into something
new and everybody is trying out and then
as many as different ways you try out
and I think you will succeed in the one
or the other by the way if anyone has a
question in the audience feel free to
raise your hand and we'll give you mic
or something or just ask
yep
that's a I'm Martin I'm a company for
sygic we have a division called Santa
Clara and we have already more than
$3,000 $3,000 videos in our platform so
no more reaching 5,000 a few months and
we we still have a struggle I would say
like the classical TV or video approach
to have the passive passive watching of
the videos in 360 or which are the
content comparing to active so what is
your point of view of to bring more it's
the way to bring more active interaction
with video or we are now we are now in
Android platform of with the new
generation on oculus will be ready in a
few weeks and then we have Samsung we
are present in O channel so if what is
your approach to bring more customers to
really ask you to to show this see the
content and to be entertained by the
content or to go more to interact with
the content or we and we are world thank
you
yeah I mean I think that I mean it's an
interesting question because there's you
know different parts the BBC of doing
different things we're doing kind of you
know we see people interested in sort of
live streaming eSports through kind of
you know VR and so on there's a big kind
of divide I think between 360 content
and real-time content and you know
there's a certain amount that you can do
to overlay one of the other I think in
everything you create again thinking of
kind of what you know what the angle is
you need to be adding value and I think
one of the problems that VR has had is
and it's the same with most kind of new
Texas people go wow there's this amazing
new thing let's build some stuff for it
okay not necessarily thinking if this is
something that the audience actually
wants and I think you have to be
thinking in any broad development you
know what who's my audience what do they
need we know what what and what can I
offer them and if you can answer those
three things and that allows you to come
up come up with a product which is going
to make it you know their life easier or
more entertaining or whatever it is then
I think you'll be successful but I think
just doing something because you hope
the market will develop
I think that's risky very risky so I
think it's really key to kind of
you know to be thinking of your consumer
always what's going to be good for them
linear and interactive I think the real
interactive is still based on mobile
it's based on VR headsets and we see a
growth that there are more and more
headsets on the market so the kind of
market is getting bigger and bigger
still with linear you have the advantage
that you can really make access to
people who don't have a headset but who
are familiar with video in general so
they understand it like that and I think
if you if you create out of that great
experiences that can be a bit more
convincing just to understand this new
evolutionary step into computing and
this kind of new platform this kind of
new interactive realities coming up
there it's a really good tool like a
technology that's kind of doing the
bridge between the two and that's why we
shouldn't underestimate really linear
base videos
from the daydream side we've seen that
actually the most used app on on day
dreamers YouTube so like linear 360
video is playing a big part and I don't
think we want to say that 360 or linear
video is some kind of a step towards the
ultimate goal which is interactive it's
not like I think as Bradley mentioned
it's really about what you're trying to
achieve and sometimes 360 video is
exactly the right format and also it's
you know often cheaper to produce so
that's a good thing too I think that was
another question in Germany hi hello
Antoine I work at pursue we were
language learning app and we've just
built a VR experience for another
platform and one of my questions is
around replayability because obviously
those experiences are quite finite and I
guess as all platforms will be looking
at retention as a key metric so how do
you make sure that you know that the
headsets just doesn't become one thing
that's just left in the in the cupboards
out of you and you know people come back
to your experiences over time I would
start by saying sorry I as I said the
pacing the bets before and what you
believe will happen you know in time to
come I personally believe that we're not
quite there yet there's a cap there's an
experience cap which is no that's a but
it's gonna come like technology is
moving extremely fast and I think
yeah you got a you gotta be there when
it goes who relevant I think you got to
be ready when putting that thing on and
whatever happens in that reality feels
relevant to you and also you got to
place those bets on what you believe is
relevant to your target audience for
example a group of young people might
want to meet up and play their favorite
game and so forth and you might want to
meet with your son or your daughter
across the world different groups some
BBC research actually that was done
recently about the kind of barriers you
might have seen it is really interesting
and one of the biggest barriers is that
people lose their headsets so you know
it's a different thing to kind of like
in a switch on your TV and interact with
content that way to actually go and find
your headset put it on go through the
kind of process of sort of putting it up
and so on and that the research found
that that was one of the most difficult
things about VR is that people tend to
do things in order of how easy they are
and VR comes to fairly sort of low down
the kind of list and that's one reason
why I think it has to have that added
value it has to be something that kind
of like you know people are going to
kind of want as a destination to come
and go to but I do think as well we're
just talking about this before that we
are in the really early stages of VR
there's been a huge amount of noise
about it and people are saying oh it's
not gonna work and you know people
aren't investing in it and so on it's
incredibly unfair because it's only
really been in its current form around
for 18 months to two years if you look
at the mobile market which has been
around for a long long time many of the
surface of the sophistication about kind
of retention and so on it's I mean
really now kind of coming to kind of
like the four and you look at the way
that kind of mobile companies sort of
reengage people and so on that's sort of
you know years of kind of R&D and
investment and tying to social channels
and so on and I think VR na are
we'll have that eventually as well and
that will help with kind of attention
and getting people to come back in and
discoverability and all those things
because actually the first mover or
smartphones they came to market in the
90s something like that but it made boom
in the 20 in the 2000s with Android with
iOS and stuff like that so there was a
quite a big period in between the first
really market phones like the Nokia back
in the days and stuff like that I think
that seeing the moving today since like
25 14 cents we do it it's really fast I
think I'm quite surprised and in
different levels I mean an adoption and
stuff like that but I think also that
the midterm or the next goal would be
that it's kind of something yeah which
is where people ask for experiences but
not because it's we are because they
asked that they heard something is
really great and they want to play it or
they want to see it or whatever I think
that will be the next go for for the
next year to your question around with
replayability there's that's kind of I
think three things that need to happen
and aligned in in in a certain way which
is hardware software and content right
so it becomes the barrier to
experiencing here it's a lot lower than
replayability is not really that much of
an issue because you can just pick this
thing up and it's cheap and it's easy
right
and I think to follow on with this one
interesting you know stat that I guess
you guys know is that you know Goldman
Sachs says by 2025 VR will become an 80
billion dollar industry taking over TV
that's interesting well what do you so
you know be that as it may what do you
think are the key steps that need to
happen in order for your to go
mainstream whatever that means
we have four if you look back on
smartphone market I mean today you have
a phenomena that people say they talk to
someone but you don't know how I mean
did I call them did they write or what
the hell did whatever you know you don't
know they just say that a communication
with someone and I think we are should
be and a are should be at the same level
more or less that it's used intuitively
like okay it's there it's something and
I do a call with my friends in the
states in 360 and I see where they are
and we can share the environment and
stuff like that so all this I think will
come but you know I think this is this
this will be more or less the kind of
level when will arrive is an interesting
kind of like adoption curve with any new
technology that it has to become sort of
you know has to be accessible to people
and sort of be something that kind of
people are familiar with and obviously
as a younger generation grows up without
tech they kind of you know they're
probably be more willing to kind of put
kind of headsets on and so on but again
I think it just comes down to kind of
like what are the applications going to
be and I think you'll probably begin to
see a you know they are finding
different areas which it's really good
at so I think it has lots of
applications for kind of business
business the business and training and
that type of thing I think there'll be a
lot more installation basically are
coming up in the next couple of years
you know you'll see that it at theme
parks you'll see it in kind of malls and
things like that and I think that again
will kind of like you know give the
general public much more exposure to it
and that's a good way for them getting
involved because it's not them doing
that at home and losing their headset or
whatever awesome okay I think we're all
out of time so thank you so much for
joining and discussing super interesting
so yeah thank you
[Applause]
you